[Musique]
on en a parlé comme le contrat du siècle
et son annulation a carrément provoqué
une crise diplomatique
il faut dire que 56 milliards d'euros ce
n'est pas le genre de pertes qui passent
inaperçues et ça questionne sur l'impact
que ça peut avoir sur l'économie
française commençons par un petit état
des lieux en matière d'armes la france
est le troisième pays exportateur au
monde derrière la russie et des états
unis elle représente 8 2% des
exportations mondiales selon le dernier
rapport de l'institut international de
recherche sur la paix de stockholm
en clair les armes sont un des fleurons
de l'industrie française
et pourtant tout n'est pas au top en
2020 comme n'importe quel secteur
d'activité les clients se sont faits
plus rares et la france a vu des prises
de commandes d'armes chuté à cause de la
pandémie passant de 8,3 milliards en
2019 à 4,9 milliards d'euros une chute
de 41% et pour les livraisons c'est
encore pire de 9,9 milliards à 4,3
milliards d'euros elles ont chuté plus
que de moitié en matière d'emploi en
2019 la ministre de la défense florence
parly estimé que l'industrie de
l'armement représenté 13% des emplois
industriels du pays deux cent mille
personnes travailleraient de manière
directe ou indirecte dans ce secteur en
france et quatre mille petites et
moyennes entreprises seraient impliqués
on comprend donc pourquoi l'état
français misent gros sur son commerce
d'armes et pourquoi il est très présent
lors de la signature des contrats avec
les pays acheteurs sans parler du fait
qu'il est bien souvent actionnaires des
entreprises fabricantes navale group le
fabricant des fameux sous marin est par
exemple détenu à 60 2 % par l'état
français normal donc que la pilule et eu
du mal à passer
[Musique]